foreign
continuation from Sir David Attenborough
for a device that was pierced by a
tube-shaped lava substance thing this
star map sure looks like it was sliced
rather than saber skewered I'm sorry but
the regular task of speaking into your
comstick would demand the necessity of a
pocket perfectly placed for such a thing
no used to risk losing it in the folds
of your front clothes like that Mom can
I
wow your mom will ping you on the comms
when it's time stay inside where you're
safe for sake this is why you
never take children on dangerous secret
missions
all right yeah I'm sure you've taken
seven steps and swiveled your head twice
I'm sure that's an in-depth enough
search to determine your sun is safe we
don't know this planet so keep chopping
with you continuing to allow the biggest
war criminal in a galaxy far far away to
babysit your son putting the zipper on
the back instead of the front I told
them to stay together but they never
listen you don't know they're not
together though you were at the ship
when they split up and Ahsoka fell over
the side all you knew is Sabine left her
helmet behind there's no evidence to
suggest ahsokin so being split up from
your point of view did you read the
script who yang
the same he does not I'm here to finish
your training but only as long as it
takes for your body to be recovered from
underwater just before drowning so let's
hop right to it one is never too old to
learn Snips Matt Lanter isn't the one
calling her Snips in this scene I won't
fight you I've heard that before putting
out that we've heard something before to
make us feel all the good nostalgic
feelings while simultaneously feeling
the confusion of being excited for
another moment when anakinator Force
fights his Protege I'll cover it but
good is a higher rank if you can't use
it every now and then if you could cover
it why don't you just start with doing
that when the dumbest Senators know to
mankind to give you the requested
resources seems like a move you should
have led with
[Music]
abilities his father Kane and Jairus was
a Jedi all the more reason why Ahsoka
should be training Jason instead of
Sabine looks like you don't have much
left to offer getting cocky when you
landed exactly one blow on the guy the
internet tells me Vader killed you so
good last time the Dave filoni had
introduced time travel to the
Star Wars Universe just to bring you
back you're gonna show me this
flashback and make me believe that
Ahsoka decided to abandon this sweet
headpiece sometime in the future
impossible no one could say goodbye to
that look at it
[Music]
uh sure yep I knew that we'd suddenly
found our way into another TV show
altogether totally knew that before
blatantly being told about it
me hi see we've immediately jumped from
the teacher having one big lesson to
teach to you must teach yourself without
skipping a beat they were following
I got them you're 14 if someone puts you
in charge it's their fault
[Music]
okay that's an incredible visual we're
gonna press our fuel reserves if I have
to hear about fuel in a Star Wars
property one more time I'm gonna stop
sending this all together actually
we both know that's a lie but I will hit
you with five cents for this annoying
carryover from The Last Jedi you do
things your way because you care this is
the same Droid that gave Ahsoka for
doing things the non-jedi way but is
clearly capable of comforting a rogue
general what an ass people don't just
vanish Into Thin Air in this world they
actually do what was he like listen if
there's any sort of backstory that we
need to know it's how the general here
either doesn't know anything about
ahsoka's master or knows the name it has
no historical understanding of who
Anakin is or what he became this is the
sort of detail to dig into cut out the
previously ons and give me a few minutes
of perspective on Hera
choosing to describe anakinator as
anything other than murderous or
conflicted by sand
says you're gonna have to get low
somehow the Droid on the high high
Cliffs picks up something in the low low
waters before anyone else and I'm
beginning to wonder if all the equipment
everyone has is really just for show
and this is why you cannot give
lightsabers to Children showrooms a
chance for perfectly clear hero stance
desktop background with a dramatic Smoky
sand filter I gave you a choice live
or die bro can't go five minutes without
trying to murder a child can he also I'm
not sure what lesson Anakin is trying to
teach Ahsoka here but I'm pretty sure
it's related to fan fiction demands for
a Vader Ahsoka standoff more than a need
for character development
ah stop it I can only change my pants so
many times
Jason doesn't react to whatever
smart-ass remark I'm sure Chopper just
made sleeping with your head at a 90
degree angle this is terrible for your
spine who cares that you're not human
vertebral health is important for any
species wearing your bed sheet will you
train me
when you teach me no I don't think
they're coming to help
programming your Droid for maximum wah
wah these space whales have essentially
become the Star Wars equivalent of the
Eagles from Lord of the Rings the Senate
oversight committee is going to
determine if your command should be
permanently suspended wow that's quite a
waste of time with that level of
incompetence the first order could take
things back over in a decade or two get
your together I don't know how you
score this but we're losing right now so
then why not pick up the hollow puck in
your hand while she's talking and at
least have some fun with how it's all
projected I mean pop her in your shoe or
power dangling from the dash upside down
make the shoot lost to a flickering
image fun before you're out of a job I
know how to follow Sabine Andy in just a
few minutes she will admit that she
actually does not if you would have told
me that the symbolic moment of ahsoka's
Resurrection would be punctuated by
Jonah style hyperdrive space whales I'd
have told you to stop eating unregulated
gummies
doesn't wish her so good luck what a
dick ap5 would have wished to soak a
good luck behold Ahsoka and her savior
era she flies she speaks with animals
she was dead once she wears white cue
the clouds in sunlight for Star Wars
Gandalf they can't interrupt the fight
in the Pod the fleet will frighten the
Pod the same Fleet that the Pod cruises
through without so much as a reaction
here in a few minutes you mean that pod
after the reason we are here is because
there was no mission is that true there
was a mission it just wasn't sanctioned
and while I'm at it what parameters did
Hera violate the X-Wing Pilots came with
their own accord and she didn't use New
Republic resources she came and the
ghost which is her personal ship I'm not
seeing any rules broken show just wants
to generate tension to drag out the run
time I just want to peek into the world
where these folks get fit for their
uniforms it seems like there'd be some
interesting conversations about how the
leg section needs a few more slouch
folds okay but you're not gonna believe
me well not with that attitude she won't
sorry kid you don't get gumdrops on your
badge you get a vent covered by a piece
of cardboard
Tarsus before you get inside the whale
five steps here Ahsoka evasive maneuvers
they clear up their path wow not since
Han listed lazily to the left have I
seen such effective evasive maneuvers
you're not listening you're only hearing
what you want to hear
don't you hear it you think the wind is
ever trying to tell us something we
don't know how to hear it anymore he was
a man who loved the outdoors
and bowling
I wonder which of your friends I'll have
you annihilate first Catra
she's mean that'll do that'll do don't
kick that'll do